I'm wondering man because you're one of
the you know obviously you were lucky
enough to be able to go on uh Joe's Joe
Rogan's podcast yeah you always hear
that like he's the king maker yeah right
did you notice I mean obviously you guys
have a crazy phone you guys got one of
the biggest patreons you guys have your
own Universe you're in you're already
selling out dates your special was doing
well but did you notice the like uptick
in everything yes after going on the
show my so My Views it was cool it was
like trending on YouTube the first
couple days and it was like then it hit
like 300 000 in like whatever two days
and then you could see it level off from
back into the views on YouTube and then
the second the Rogan dropped it doubled
it hit another 300 000 in the next two
days and that's completely it would have
done this right but with Rogue and it
did this
and it was like it might even be any
more I've been like two and a half X or
whatever yeah you see and he's the
[ __ ] greatest the the experience is
intense because like we're chilling
we're hanging out we're leaning back you
know
how how many people are listening to
Rogan and he's gonna give you every
ounce of attention possible so if I
don't return that I'm a giant [ __ ]
you know he's locked in he's locked the
[ __ ] in yeah and for that guy worth that
much with that much power to be locked
in for two hours with you or however
long if I don't return it who the [ __ ]
am I that's right so I was like you know
what I mean like yeah I went there
during uh like covet I went there with
Freddie Gibbs and um
you know I I had it in my head uh what I
thought it might be yeah but it's like
kind of like in like a little like
business complex where there's like a
doctor's office and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
and I was like I was a little I was like
damn I really expected to come to like
some giant Warehouse with like weights
everywhere I think there's a lot of [ __ ]
in the back there probably is yeah
because Andrew is telling me you had to
get [ __ ] swapped just to walk in
there yeah yeah yeah they were playing
they're not playing if Andrew's telling
me he did like a like he Joe shot like a
bow and arrow from like 100 yards out
and just like crazy hit some crazy
Bullseye or something but it was in that
facility so I think it's a whole thing